Hey, you gonna come in the water with us CZ?
Nah, I think I'm just gonna kick back and grab some sun.
Are you sure dude? It's gonna be like the last good day of the summer.
You guys go ahead.
OK..
Bryce: Let's go!
Ryan: Yeah!
Guys?
Anyone out there?
Thank you for watching Microhorror: The End.
If you like this video, remember to like this video.
Go down in the comments and let me know what your favorite Microhorror has been.
If you missed any episodes, I'll leave a link to the playlist so you can go check out any of them.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every other week,
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.